you know before donald trump ranted at  the nra about how great guns are and  more guns and more places like he  recently did he previously has actually  said we need more gun safety regulations  he said there are some firearms that you  shouldn't be able to get when you're 18  you should have to wait until you're 21.  it's on video it doesn't make sense that  i have to wait till i'm 21 to get a  handgun but i can get this weapon at 18.  i don't know so i was just curious as to  what you did in your bill  we didn't we didn't address in this  presentation i think why cause you're  afraid of the nra right so as with  abortion as with him supposedly being a  christian  none of this stuff is true trump will  say anything and do anything to appeal  to whatever crowd he's in front of that  day and appeal to whoever he thinks he  needs to appeal to in order to win some  election or earn some donation or curry  some favor